ما تريد القيام به هو فصل كل
هذا الجزء العلوي من الدماغ هنا
من جذع الدماغ من الجانب الآخر
من الدماغ ومن نوع
الأجزاء العميقة هنا عندما
بدأت بريانا بودلي البالغة من العمر ستة أعوام تعاني من
النوبات التي كانت تعاني منها  تم تشخيصها في البداية بأنها مصابة
بالصرع عندما لم ينجح العلاج،
وكشف التصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي أنها مصابة باضطراب عصبي نادر
يعرف باسم رأس معين والسفتي، وكان من
الصعب أن أشعر بالصدمة لأنها يمكن أن
يكون لديها شيء من هذا القبيل يتسبب في
تقلص الدماغ في هذه
المساحات، لذا  لدينا أدوية يمكنها
السيطرة عليه أه مبدئيا أو على الأقل
تأخيره أم الذي كان يستخدمه البنا ولكن
كان هناك حاجة إلى خطوة جراحية إضافية
لمساعدة بريانا فقط على فصل
أنسجة المخ الملتهبة ولا حتى
إزالتها مجرد فصلها يكفي لإيقاف
المرض تماما  ومن
المحتمل أن يكون علاجه بشكل أساسي، حيث يعد
فصل نصف الدماغ
مهمة دقيقة للغاية، فقد كانت مثل
عملية جراحية مدتها 10 ساعات، لقد كانت 10 ساعات طويلة،
فبدلاً من قطع الدماغ، يمكنك
في الواقع استخدام هذه الفتحة الطبيعية في
الدماغ التي تسمى الشق السيلفي هنا
الذي يمكّنك من النظر من خلال
شق سيفان وقطع
المادة البيضاء من المهاد هنا ويمكننا أن
نرى تقاطعًا ويمكننا أيضًا فصل
كوربوس كولوم هنا عن
الجانب الآخر من الدماغ، وهو
الجانب الأيمن من دماغ بريانا
منغلقة داخل جمجمتها لبقية
حياتها، لذلك بعد الجراحة، يتم
إيقاف الجانب الأيسر من جسدها بالكامل،
وستفقد جزءًا من
رؤيتها في عينها اليسرى، ومن ثم
لن تتمتع بالمهارات الحركية الدقيقة.
يدها ويدها اليسرى، التعافي
بشكل خاص لشخص صغير
مثل براين هو أمر رائع جدًا
أتوقعه في غضون شهر أو نحو ذلك سوف
تمشي، كان علي أن أطمئن أمي بأن
براين سيظل هو نفس
الشخص تمامًا حتى  بعد فصل نصف
دماغها، وهذا صحيح، أنت تعلم أن ذلك
لن يغير شخصيتك،
أمامها رحلة طويلة وأعتقد أن
العلاج الطبيعي سيكون قاسيًا عليها لكنها
ستتجاوزه
وستكون مجرد طبيعية  طفل